Our first speaker against the motion identity politics is tearing society.
Apart is Dawn foster Dawn. Please take to the podium, guardian columnist,
who writes on politics, social affairs and economics,
and also a staff writer for Jacobin magazine Dawn.
Some of you might've noticed I am a woman, I'm white.
I have a disability.
And when I think about politics and when I talk about politics,
a lot of those identities come into it. So when I think about austerity,
I look at how austerity affects certain groups more than others.
So in particular, austerity affects women, uh,
82% of all cuts that the government have made impact women.
If you look at the, if you look at the pay gap, for instance,
women are paid less than men, but if you narrow it down,
black women are paid a lot less than, than other than other people.
Um, so when you think about politics,
identity does have to come into it because everybody experiences things
differently personally, but also in terms of economics,
in terms of how it affects the community, et cetera,
I'm want to think about the people will want to come across the people who
complain about this. It always seems to be exclusively boomers,
sorry.
I am closer in age to Carl's daughter and Como.
So I, um,
I am of the generation that is part partly interested in
identity politics. I don't think it,
I don't think it deflates things. I think, you know,
people live their life in a normal way and obviously your
identity is part of that. So everything that affects you,
everything that makes you makes up makes it the person that is you include
in your likes, your hobbies or dislikes, et cetera,
it all comes together to form a whole person.
And I don't think that talking to people and understanding that people
have different views,
different experiences of life because of different identities.
I don't think it actually like deflates things.
I don't think it puts people in a box.
I think it allows us to be more expensive with policy.
I think it allows us to look at political policy and think
about how different groups will be affected by it and that, you know,
and therefore stop discrimination within that kind of thing.
Um, there's a lot,
there was a huge amount of concern about universities,
about people being no platformed about people not being allowed to speak,
et cetera. And I always find it really,
really fascinating that so many people get upset by a small number of students
in the student union when almost nobody else will have heard of
these little, the small society, Z small groups. Um,
and I think it's,
I think the big problem is that we have older people who have
columns in big magazines,
huge access to the media constantly say that they are being silenced.
I know this because they write constantly that they are being silenced.
They go on TV to talk about the fact that they have been silenced.
And, you know, I think if they were,
I wouldn't be constantly hearing about them. And I think,
you know,
I think actually identity politics helps those people because it allows them to
constantly place articles in the spectator in
spiked magazine, in all sorts of places,
talking about the fact that they have been silenced and that identity politics
is ruining their life, et cetera. And you know,
thinking about Lionel speech,
I have a lot of friends who are white men and I don't look at them and think,
good Lord. You're so privileged. It's disgusting because they are my friends.
And I don't think of people in small, you know, I,
I don't put people in a small boxes.
I don't look at them as having a tick box on their chest.
That explains things about them. Um, I think that, you know, for instance,
me having, uh,
having a disability changes my life than what I'm in the hospital. A lot,
my friends know that and come and see me,
but it doesn't really change anything else. I might need some things like,
for instance, if we decide to have strobe lighting here,
I wouldn't be able to sit on stage, but that's about it.
Don't do that. And I find it really,
really fascinating that the big panic comes from older people are very,
very small number of older people who, you know,
who has, you know,
Lionel was saying that the people who are into internet politics are
relatively wealthy, tend to be white, et cetera. Um,
but whenever I read articles about people being silent so that people being
kicked out by identity politics, it's always homeowners in their fifties.
It's always people who are relatively comfortable. Haven't lived through, uh,
the, you know, the global financial crash. It didn't really affect them.
I, it seems, it seems such an obsession with,
with those people. Um,
I've met people who were absolutely desperate to get removed from panels just
because they wanted to talk about the backlash that came with it.
And they knew that if they were removed from a small panel in student union,
they can make a huge amount of money talking about it, you know,
going on the BBC,
talking about how they were silent writing as a spectator about they were
silence and absolutely nobody at any point thinking why
clearly aren't clearly this, this person's being published everywhere. Um,
I think identity politics is actually really,
really helpful in terms of making sure that we think more
deeply about how policy affects people about how we can stop, kind of get,
you know, gaps in admission to university,
how we can stop people being paid less,
how we can look at the fact that if you are disabled,
you are less likely to get a job and how we can change things to bring
other people in. Um, and I think that,
I think that we have to move past the terrifying fear that a lot of boomers
have around this, uh, you know, people, when I look at my friends,
I don't, I, you know, tick box in my head that appears like,
like some kind of scifi thing that breaks down what they are and who they are.
We might have conversations about kind of, you know,
so I was having a conversation with my friend the other day about the fact that
they had been the victim of a homophobic attack. Um,
but identity doesn't always come up and sometimes it does. And it's very,
I think it's a lot more useful to talk about it and think about how
discrimination happens and how we can stop that from happening.
One, one really, really key bit. Uh,
I think David will talk about this is university admissions.
So for instance, Oxford had a huge race problem. They have a huge class problem.
Um, and you know,
bringing that up and talking about it means that they will actually take some,
some action and think about that.
There have been some court cases where people have looked at the fact that,
you know, certain policies are bound to affect women.
Therefore they are discriminatory, uh, other policies, for instance,
like exclusively seems to hit disabled people.
And those people have gone to court and talked about the fact they'd been
discriminated against and often won the cases and changed the policy.
So I think that, you know, if we want to have a more equal society,
there is no way we can do that without thinking about identity,
without thinking about how certain things mean that other people find it
harder to get into certain jobs,
find it harder to reach certain things or even, you know,
come into a building because there isn't a wheelchair ramp. Um,
so I think that identity politics is not about deciding who,
who is the villain, who is the most privileged,
who we should never ever talk about and,
and attack and be talking about their privilege.
I think it's much more about making sure that our society is more welcoming to
people and that political policy doesn't discriminate against
individuals and big groups.
It doesn't moment austerity massively affects women. And it massively,
if you are a woman and you are disabled,
you're doubly discriminated against by certain policies that is identity
politics. And, you know,
I think we need to remember that if we are making policy,
it needs to be more equal. It needs to make sure that for instance,
if you are a young black person and you're applying for a certain job
or a placement university,
you weren't discriminated against by the way that the interview takes place.
And so I think identity politics is about equality.
It's about making sure that everybody has the same access and that access might
be slightly different based on their identity. Um,
and I think that it's led to a lot of people thinking more deeply about how they
act and how society should be built.
So I am against emotion.
I think that we should be more equal.
And I think that identity politics is key to that. We can't move past identity.
We can't ignore identity.
And I think that maybe at some point, the boomers will understand that.
[Inaudible].